you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive we'll see what's making
the headlines with royal author and
historian sarah gristwood and the editor
of the jewish chronicle jake wallace
simons
but first let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you
the front of the express shows a
striking photo of the queen's coffin
with the headline queen's saddest
journey begins
the same photo covers at the front of
the metro their headline our gracious
queen
the final journey home reads the front
of the mirror
and the daily star reiterates this
message again alongside a picture of her
majesty
her last great journey reads the front
of the daily telegraph
the front of the eye reads queen's final
journey begins
the saddest journey now the long goodbye
reads the front of the daily mail
the front of the financial times shows
the same photo but its headline focuses
on russia's war with ukraine saying
ukraine offensive makes significant
gains
the front of the guardian also looks to
ukraine their headline russia launches
revenge attacks as ukraine offensive
gathers pace
and we are joined tonight by sarah
griswood and jake wallace simons uh
welcome to you both thank you very much
for coming down to buckingham palace for
us um let's start with the i front page
and um as many of them um will be
covering the final journey um in in
various guises it's the same headline
but that's been the story of today
hasn't it there's really only one
picture in town and that's it
but it is interesting because always
with the royals there's two things going
on there's this amazing pageantry i mean
the colors the ceremony the sort of
sense of you know chivalry and tradition
but on the other of course there's some
very serious
business if you like with the royal
family in scotland in the fact the queen
died at balmoral means that scotland
edinburgh has a much larger role to play
than usual because you know of the time
she's that her coffin will spend at
hollywood and then at st giles so
there'll be that that that
procession
up the royal mile
and of course it's a time when there's
talk about you know another scottish
independence referendum and we had hints
didn't we that the queen was very much
hoping there would not be that break so
in a sense
underneath the pageantry
the you know the gold and the lilies and
the scarlet and the uniforms
there's something quite important for
the monarchy going on
jake what did you make of what we saw
today
well it was extraordinary wasn't it all
the um
all the the pomp and circumstance and
pageantry and ceremony um you know mixed
with the
uh very serious business of moving from
one monarch to the next and all the all
the sort of
procedures of state that need to be
followed i think for me as probably as
for many other people in britain uh it's
really helping me come to terms with the
fact that the queen actually has passed
away because she's been here all my life
and from the majority of most people in
britain's lives
and in a way it's it's left us in a
sense of shock and disbelief and seeing
by degrees
these ceremonies being rolled out and
moving from one stage to the next so
slowly i mean the you know the the um
procession itself from barramural to
edinburgh took six hours this is almost
like a metaphor for everybody going
through the stages of grief and finally
coming to accept we're entering a new
reign and a new chapter in our history
that's interesting yes it's a good point
because in fact again because the queen
died at balmoral there are even more
stages than usual the actual
mourning process is a little longer than
usual and perhaps that's appropriate for
a monarch whose reign was so much longer
than his usual perhaps that that those
sort of slow stages
of ceremony of the different places the
coffin will rest does actually give us
all a chance to catch our breaths and
realize what's happening
the uh telegraph they've echoed the
words of
king charles now king charles iii her
last
great journey and she was a very well
traveled monarch had been to most of i
think part two of the commonwealth
countries that she presided over and
they today in their turn were
commemorating her
yes they were prince charles to king
charles there we are
um had a meeting indeed with with many
commonwealth representatives and that's
somewhere he's going to be very anxious
to continue his mother's legacy
it was something very important to her
the commonwealth did it's interesting
that she you know she heard all those
years ago that she was going to become
queen out in kenya not at home out in a
commonwealth country that is now
commonwealth country um but ended the
journey of her life very much at home
not only in the united kingdom but as
you said in in scotland balmoral was
something that she loved so much in a
way her spiritual home in so many ways
was scotland and indeed it's if you
think back it's the only moment that i
can remember where she was accused of
breaking her neutrality when she made
that comment during the scottish
referendum saying if everyone thinks
very carefully before they cast their
vote which was interpreted as being a
pro-unionist uh statement yes that's the
only time she's done that and now you
know but still that was that even then
open to interpretation there was a lot
of reading through the lines let's be
honest but you know the fact that she
ended the journey of her life there uh
in a way was was an indication of
of how much she loves scotland as the
heart of the united kingdom yeah it's
very very clear that her love of uh
scotland and balmoral which was a
private residence yes i think that's the
point that that as you know someone said
she hung up her crown on the gate when
she went in
sometimes there were times when balmoral
head if you like didn't serve her well
notably after the death of diana the
royal family were at balmoral of course
and if they hadn't been perhaps they'd
have reacted a little faster to the
public mood down south but no it was
enormously important to her she always
said as a as a girl that if she didn't
have to
become queen she'd want to be a country
woman with lots of horses and dogs and
that's exactly what she could be at
balmoral yes she was that as well wasn't
she was she was somebody referred to her
as a when she was at balmoral she was
mrs windsor
and
not not the queen right let's have a
look at the mirror um pages 14 and 15 of
the mirror and this is about um the
prince of wales
to be trusted lieutenant let's take a
look at that
that front page and we see him in the in
the background supporting his his father
which he said will be his role now to
support his father as king charles iii
well we could absolutely see that coming
couldn't we
prince charles as then he was had
already begun with prince william's
active assistance this idea of a slimmed
down monarchy
there's always been the debate hasn't
there
whether the royals should drop some of
the palaces and pageantry or whether
that's what we all want to see
and
charles's compromise prince charles's
compromise then was quite sensibly just
to try and trim down some of the
extraneous members so balcony
appearances would be just this
absolutely core group and you could very
much see
he and prince william
working together of course the question
now
is whether prince william prince william
will take over some of the work
of the charit the prince of wales's
charities
which a
charles king may no longer have time for
but also might open the way in some
cases to that element of controversy
that's going to be much more difficult
for him as sovereign than as prince jake
do you see a lot of those roles falling
to prince william now
i do i think it's interesting to note
that partly i suppose because of the
queen's great longevity uh prince uh
prince charles as he was then became
king charles at a very old age in fact i
think he's the oldest monarch to have
taken over
in our history at 73 and that means of
course that he'll likely rely or benefit
from relying upon uh prince william to
take on some of the duties uh of of the
overall responsibility of being a
monarch to help him be his left hand as
the mirror's headline suggests and it
suggests a different dynamic between the
two of them that existed between the
queen and then prince charles where she
very much was this very well established
um
matriarch figure that everybody just
looked up to and respected and took on
so much of a burden and now you know
prince charles taking over as king
charles is going to it looks like
sharing it a bit more with his according
to the mirror lieutenant um uh prince
william
and sarah the the king has said that
obviously he knows that his role has now
changed and perhaps won't be able to be
as vocal as he has been in the past
about certain issues do you think that
although he won't be publicly vocal
those issues will be continued to be
aired by prince william yes and i think
that one the one big issue that in a
sense we all want charles to continue
with as king is of course the
environment
questions of climate change i think if
word slips out that king charles behind
the scenes is discreetly pressuring
ministers on that front it will only
increase his popularity and indeed
increase this idea
useful for the royal family that the
royals are in some way you know our
our
bulwark against the the nasty
politicians i don't i mean i wouldn't be
surprised if william actually becomes
more reticent in his views because
over the past few decades we've had a
situation where the queen showed this
great exemplar
of not getting involved in in politics
not letting her views be shown but
charles had slipped from that and he's
had the from the black spider letters to
the environmental campaign to the
carbuncle on the face of an old friend
his views have been known which makes it
more difficult now for him to become
king and to then hold back from those
views because everybody knows what he
thinks already whereas i think prince
william may learn from that and given
that he's his proximity to taking over
as king is much shorter than
than prince charles ever was he may
learn from that and think well now is
the time to start holding back from
expressing my views in preparation for
becoming king at some point in the next
20 you know 30 years no that's that's
quite interesting analysis so we shall
see um and uh the mirror is taking a
look at um the type of of king that
charles will be according to them king
charles will not stop
for lunch uh he's going to
he's going to be very very busy and will
work very very hard
take us into that so that's
that's quite a headline isn't it
the king will not stop for lunch yes i
love the bit about how we breakfasted on
fruit and seeds you know it sounds
rather
um
they were all boiled to different stages
so he could you know knock the tops off
all of them and decide which one was her
oh i hadn't heard that interesting
but basically the article is is saying
what jake oh his i mean his punishing
routine that he that he that he has
anyway even before he became king um
begins with breakfast of seasonal fruits
and seeds and a cup of tea goes straight
through doesn't have lunch has a break
for a walk at one o'clock sometimes with
the then the duchess of cornwall with
camilla um but doesn't actually stop
until five o'clock when he sits down for
tea with now the queen consort then has
supper at 8 30 sharp and then back to
work again
until 10 30. so you know back-to-back
sessions of 45 minutes each really a
punishing punishing schedule um which
you know you wouldn't see from the
outside you always seem so relaxed and
jovial and at home in his own skin and
yet you know all the time has this you
know workaholic side to him according to
the mirror anyway and i suppose that
will set him in good stead for taking on
the responsibilities of monarch yes one
would think so just very quickly sarah
let's have a look at the metropolitan
archbishop welby uh is describing uh the
monikers having his mother's healing
ability i know
all as a tudor historian all i could
think then was how monarchs used to
touch for the king's evil you know
touching that the sovereign was supposed
to be able to touch someone and their
scrofula would go away
precisely and i got a sudden flash of
that
so it's curious how these you know very
old ideas
somehow still echo through in our
language when we talk about the royals
there's a very clear idea behind it
though which was that when the queen
spoke to people as individuals she made
them feel special and the attention from
the monarch that she gave so generously
made them feel um buoyed up and healed
and according to the archbishop prince
prince charles then and king charles now
has the same ability to focus on someone
make them feel like they have his total
undivided attention i've heard that also
from them the former chief rabbi lord
sacks also described the queen meeting
holocaust survivors and staying much
longer than her scheduled time before to
allow to speak to all of them in detail
very interesting jake and sarah thank
you very much for the moment we'll see
you in the next hour